hey guys Pete here I wasn't planning on
making another Westworld video before
the finale but I was reading all the
stuff this morning and I saw this quote
from Jimmy Simpson and the new little
teaser clip that they put out on the
Jimmy Fallon show so I thought I'd go
ahead and make one more plan is I'm
going to go over all the theories that
are currently out there or at least the
best ones I think and talk about what
the ending of the show might look like
this season
it will contain spoilers for everything
that's happened up through episode 9 and
it'll also involve major speculation
about what might happen in episode 10
with that out of the way let's jump
right into it so JJ Abrams was on Jimmy
Fallon and he brought a clip with him of
the season finale it's a forty second
clip and it has Charlotte visiting dr.
Ford in his office telling him that he's
about to retire she explains that after
he announces his new narrative that
he'll also announced his retirement
which is a lot of foreshadowing to me
because he makes mention that aren't you
afraid I'm going to smash all my toys
and go home and then she goes into the
idea that no because she knows him and
that's one of the great things of the
job but we've seen enough to know not to
underestimate dr. Ford at this point so
the other thing I read was this quote
from Jimmy Simpson and this is what
prompted me to make the video so when
asked if an annoying cliffhanger might
be in the works this was his answer
let's see well I would say I was
definitely on the edge of my seat all
the way until I got the ten script I
think we all had different ideas and
then one 10 came I think I could speak
for most of the cast the general feeling
was like holy effing [ __ ] because
basically what they've done is they've
somehow tied up everything you wanted to
know and then pointed out this whole
world of other stuff that you hadn't
really thought of that now you really
really want to know - it's not some
[ __ ] cliffhanger where you're like
oh what now it's like oh my god thank
you and I can't wait for more so I think
we can all agree that that sounds pretty
exciting now let's look at all the
things we want to know answers to and
what I think are the best theories about
their outcome usually I just try to
present
different theories and possibilities but
at this point we're at go time so I'm
just gonna lay it out there what I think
is the most likely ending so we can't
have this conversation if we aren't all
in agreement about the three timeframes
that exist in the series we have an
anchor character who shows us what they
are and that's Angela she exists in all
three time frames and her character is
different in each one she carries a
parasol in the oldest time frame this is
35 years ago roughly and it's the period
of time before the park actually opened
and welcomed in guests the next period
of time is when William and Logan were
there if you're getting really confused
or if things are throwing you off just
think about it like this all of what we
see there happened 30 years ago the big
scene that made this confusing and made
a lot of people doubt the multiple time
frames was when Dolores walks off into
the woods and sees William in reality
he's not actually in the woods she
wanders off glitching out and she starts
to have memories that overlap so she's
remembering something that happened 30
years ago
rather than those two events being
something that happened back-to-back we
see this with Maeve all the time
she even tells Felix that she can't tell
what's now and what's then and that is
all the real evidence we need on that
now what the man in black is in the park
and what we see with Ford and Charlotte
and everything else going on that's in
present time so roughly thirty years ago
Angela was a greeter we saw her welcome
William to the park and in the present
time she's working with Wyatt so the
fact that William and the man in black
are in the park at different times is
indisputable at this point the next
thing we're gonna find out in the finale
is that he is actually the man in black
this has been a popular theory since
episode 1 or 2 and there's really no
other logical conclusion I know some
people hold on to the idea that it might
be Logan but that just doesn't hold up
if you really look at it so that's gonna
be the first reveal as that man in black
and William are the same person in the
same way that they started showing the
logos at different times to sort of push
the idea that there were multiple time
frames they really accelerate showing
this knife over and over again
in the last episode to show us that that
knife has been wielded by William and
wielded by the man in black I think
we're also gonna find out how things
play out between Ford and the board
I think he's anticipated their movements
on trying to get rid of him and this
entire narrative thing is going to be
him playing his ace I'm not exactly sure
how that's gonna play out and what role
Mei plays in it but I do feel pretty
confident that Dolores will turn out to
be Wyatt in the narrative why do I think
that well for more that's a popular
theory that a lot of people have broken
down and it makes a lot of sense if you
look at the photographs of the scene
where Dolores is standing she's sort of
in the same place that why it was in
Teddy's old remembering of it so it
feels like when we see Ford in the
trailer with Teddy and Dolores that is a
pretty good indication that his thing is
centered around those two characters and
is based in the truth that happened at
that time we know Arnold was killed
according to Luke to Dolores memory but
we don't actually know what Dolores is
Cornerstone is as much as the
cornerstone has been emphasized all this
time especially when it comes down to
Maeve overriding her own and how they've
been revealing that we have no idea what
the current de Dolores has as a
cornerstone the man in black came to the
park with the test he says it was to see
if he could feel anything once he killed
Maeve and her daughter but what he ended
up finding out was is that he saw Maeve
appear to be alive really alive like
almost in comparison to himself you know
where he doesn't feel like he feels
anything so on his next trip back he
immediately goes to the Abernathy ranch
and that's where we see him drag Dolores
into the barn now when we first saw that
scene we didn't know him or anything
else about him so we assumed that he was
just a psycho and then he probably took
her in there and violently raped her as
the seasons gone on that seems less
likely because we've seen him act in a
gaming kind of relation with every
decision he's made before so I think
there's a pretty good chance that he was
trying to wake her up and make her feel
alive like he saw happen with Maeve
whatever actually happened we don't know
and we may get that as a reveal but even
we don't we know that shortly after that
happened she was taken into the barn
again by the host and that's where she
went off her loop wandering into the
woods so at that point she lost touch
with reality and started to relive this
time that she remembered that is
triggered by the reveries being
introduced to thirty years ago when she
went on the similar journey to the maze
with William like in the last video I
mentioned that I I do think we'll see
what's gonna happen with Maeve I don't
think there's gonna be a cliffhanger
there but I'm really not certain how
that's gonna play out the same goes for
Elsie and Stubbs I think we'll find out
what's happened to them with what's
going on with them but at the same time
I don't think there's strong evidence to
do anything except speculate you know as
to where they're at or why it's going on
ultimately I think Ford's either behind
it all or he's not
so we'll likely find out what's going on
with it in the finale I also think we'll
learn more about Arnold's death and if
we think about Teddy story when he told
the man in black about Wyatt he says
that he killed the general and then he
turned on Teddy so could this be the
idea that Dolores kills Arnold and then
we keep seeing this thing of her
shooting herself in the head that could
be her way to silence the pain I think
that'll be the most satisfying part of
the finale you know we know we have 90
minutes here so it'll be good to get a
real explanation of what happened back
then I hope that we get a clear
understanding of what Arnold was up to
and how his experiment with the maze and
Dolores and this death wish that he had
or seemingly had and how that's affected
forward over all these years that may be
wishful thinking but hey Jimmy Simpson
said we're gonna find out everything and
what do you guys think I mean what do
you think about this idea that there's
something else going on that we didn't
know we wanted to know about is he
talking about the casual viewer or is he
talking about people like us that have
been tearing this thing apart for the
last couple months I don't know there's
a lot more we could get into but let's
do that in the comments I'm really
excited about the finale I hope you guys
are too I'll be putting out my recap and
theory talk as soon as it's over so hit
up the comments and let's talk about it
till then please like the video if you
had fun watching it and make sure to
subscribe thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon
[Music]